We lost about seven years by the Bush
administration dropping the partnership
for new generation of vehicles that was
coming along at the end of the Clinton
administration much.
I it under Vice President Gore's
leadership actually,
um,
and moving to a hydrogen passenger
vehicles,
hydrogen,
um,
has its uses as chemical and chemical
plants and the like,
it might even someday be a reasonable
fuel for,
uh,
for putting in fuel cells and vehicles
for something that is centrally fueled,
like say a fleet of school buses,
but to have a hydrogen distribution
system at neighborhood filling stations
all over the country,
uh,
with reforming hydrogen,
putting natural gas in each filling
station.
Reformers,
uh,
storing explosive hydrogen on a pumping,
on and on.
I had approximately said that I thought
that was going to cost hundreds of
billions of dollars.
And I was talking with a former
secretary of energy who's a big fan of
hydrogen,
um,
not long ago.
And he said,
no,
Jim,
not hundreds of billions,
easily,
way over a trillion,
trillion,
trillion there before you know it,
it adds up.
Um,
whereas the only infrastructure change
you need to drive a plugin hybrid is an
extension cord,
whether it's new solar companies,
then film solar,
Nano solar,
solar coming off the collectors coming
off the production line at a square
meter,
a second.
Um,
new types of wind turbines.
It can be used on individual buildings
and houses,
not necessarily propeller like spinning
turbans,
but other designs,
vertical designs,
uh,
battery improvements,
making quite plausible.
A 40 mile driving on,
uh,
as a,
as a plugin on overnight electricity
before you need any gasoline.
If you can do that in general motors,
since that's what they're going to be
producing in 2010.
All right?
That's in model year.
That's just two years and a bit from
now.
If you can do that,
you,
uh,
we'll see.
Well over half the cars in the country
that are plugins driving effectively on
no gasoline,
no liquid fuel,
because the average car goes just a
little over 30 miles a day.
And if you have a 40 mile battery
Ballpark,
you're going to be getting a hundred to
120 miles per gallon of gasoline.
Now if you replaced that gasoline with
85% ethanol,
and let's say it's cellulosic ethanol,
so we're not going to add more and more
to the corn crunch and so forth,
uh,
then you're getting somewhere up in the
range of 500 miles per gallon of
gasoline.
And you don't have to preach at people
about not driving suv is if they have an
issue.
Vinny,
that's a plugin hybrid.
And when it uses liquid fuel is running
on e 85,
maybe they're only getting 150 to 200
miles a gallon of gasoline.
But for a chevy suburban,
how bad is that?
Uh,
you know,
sometimes people need big cars.
They gotta be able to have them if they
need them.
Uh,
what the problem is not the cars,
it's the fuel and people both from the
national security perspective and from
the global warming perspective or
zeroing in more and more on oil as a big
part of the problem.
I think,
uh,
um,
it's,
uh,
I think it's promising.
Uh,
I it,
it's not something you can say is,
is here within the next five years,
but,
but you will within five years see
plugin hybrids on production lines.
You'll see increases in production of
alternative liquid fuels.
You'll see most cars coming off the
production lines being flexible fuel
vehicles so they can use ethanol,
ethanol,
renewable,
uh,
butanol,
et cetera.
I think there's some simple things that
government mandates are good for.
Flexible fuel vehicles is one,
the change you need is simply a little
bit of different type of material in the
fuel line and some valves and a slight
software reprogramming.
It costs less than a hundred dollars a
car on the production line.
It's much less of a big deal than seat
belts.
Uh,
Brazil,
a few years ago,
I think around 2002 or three,
just ordered new vehicles shipped to
them or produced domestically to be
flexible fuel vehicles that could use
either ethanol or gasoline in any
mixture.
Uh,
in two years they went from 5% to 75% of
the new cars being flexible fuel
vehicles.
So something that simple,
I don't see any reason not to mandate.
What is a really bad idea is for the
government to mandate a solution to the
fuel issue.
It's tried it twice in the last 30 years
and it's massively botched it both
times.
One is,
it tried to come up,
uh,
with,
in the Carter administration,
they tried to come up with a synthetic
fuel operation.
The syn fuels corporation.
It was hugely expensive.
It wouldn't have been affordable and
less oil and stayed way up close to,
well 70 to $100 a barrel.
Anyway.
So in 1985,
the Sovi the Saudis drop the bottom out
of the,
the oil market,
I think probably in part to cause
trouble for the Soviets,
which was good because it was the
beginning of the end of the Soviet he
economy.
But one of the other problems,
uh,
they,
created was they bankrupted the synfuels
corporation,
uh,
which was understandable.
And then we'd been through all this,
this nonsense about the hydrogen family
car,
uh,
for,
much of the last seven years.
And the Bush administration,
the government does not have a good
record of picking solutions that ought
to stay out of the business of picking
solutions.
What it ought to do is enable
competition.
Flexible fuel vehicles enable
competition between other types of
liquid fuel.
Um,
battery improvements enable competition
between electricity and liquid fuels.
As you can tell,
I genuinely think plugins are going to
have a huge impact once people realize
that they can not only go into a
showroom and buy a reasonably priced car
that they can plug into their garage
socket drive for much of the day on
effectively penny a mile electricity
because off peak overnight power is
bound a nickel,
a kilowatt hour and much of the country,
five kilowatt hour charge.
So say it's something between one and 2
cents a mile.
Nonetheless,
gasoline now is 10,
12,
14 cents a mile.
So you're driving,
it's something close to one 10th the
cost that you're usually driving that,
that makes a big difference in some
people's,
uh,
budgets.
And the other thing is that there's a
concept called V two g or vehicle to
grid,
which after you charged your plugin
hybrid,
let's say you get a charge by midnight
and I have a timer on it,
you can make it available to the utility
from midnight to 6:00 AM when,
let's say you leave for work,
for stabilization of the grid and for
what's called spinning reserves.
That is a power outages.
Those two together are only about 5% of
what utilities need to buy about.
Been about $12 billion a year worth of
fossil fuels,
mainly natural gas because natural gas
tends to be what is turned on and off
quickly since it's amenable to that.
Well,
you know,
that amount of money if it's divided up
fairly between the utilities and the,
uh,
and the,
the consumers,
uh,
there's a,
a professor at the University of,
uh,
Delaware Kimpton who is writing articles
about this and saying,
you know,
you realize that could be something up
in the range of $2,000 a year for the
owner of a plugin hybrid.
Now let's think about this a minute.
Not only am I driving it a 10th the
cost,
but somebody is paying me close to $200
a month.
Heck,
that's a major share of my car payment
just to leave my car plugged in
overnight.
Hey,
where's that dealer's showroom?
You know,
so,
um,
I think once and different than
utilities or,
or interested in this and to different
degrees,
but in California,
if you'd talked to pg and e for example,
they are really enthusiastic about this,
uh,
concept.
So there could be a substantial interest
in a lot of people,
uh,
in,
in moving toward plugin hybrids when sir
available.
There is no doubt Toyota has led the way
with the Prius,
but General Motors did a very important
thing back in early January when they
announced to the production of the volt,
their plugin hybrid.
And then a few weeks ago on National
Public Radio,
I'm Bob Lutz,
a very senior,
he's vice chairman of the board and I'm
a man,
very much identified with large cars and
fast cars.
Uh,
he announced they're going to be in
production on plugin hybrids in 2010.
And,
uh,
you know,
you'd have thought to from what he was
saying about oil that he was president
of the Sierra Club.
Uh,
it was just from my point of view.
Great.
Um,
what's interesting is that Toyota got it
early and I think gm has gotten it now,
which is that for Americans they don't,
and they shouldn't have any particular
problem with the cars.
I mean,
look,
I had three little boys at a stage in my
life where I was driving eight,
nine kids around to soccer practice and
boy scouts and so forth.
I needed my chevy suburban people ought
to be able to have the cars they want.
The problem's not the cars,
it's the fuel.
And so as long as what you're doing is
trying to persuade Detroit to increase
the cafe standards a mile or two or
three or four or five or whatever per
gallon,
what they're tying to do is ring more
mileage by redesigning the car sometimes
and relatively cheap,
sometimes in a little bit more expensive
ways to wring that out.
But if you say,
uh,
and,
and they lobby against it,
and they probably could have been
ordered to do it much faster than
they've done it,
but from their point of view,
consumers wanted big,
fast cars.
So all the,
we've had a huge amount of improvement
in,
in technology and vehicles in the last
20 years.
Virtually all of it has gone in to speed
and horsepower,
not into,
into fuel efficiency.